hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast doing more with less
stem cells regulate their fate by
altering their stiffness presented by
dr. Melek asaram project leader
postdoctoral associate biomedical
sciences and regenerative technologies
Institute for macro molecular chemistry
University of Freiburg Germany I'm
Christie Joel of lab rats will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by lab roots and sponsored by thermo
Fisher Scientific to learn more about
our sponsor please visit thermo Fisher
com forward slash cell culture heroes
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by using the ask a question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
and now like to introduce our presenter
dr. Melek asaram for a complete
biography on dr. Sorrell please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen doctors to REM you may now begin
your presentation
hello everybody thank you so much for
joining our webinar today it's a great
pleasure to have you all here my name is
Malik asaram and I'm a project leader in
universe of tribal Institute for
macromolecular chemistry and by a center
for biological signalling studies today
I will talk about one of my recent
publications which was published a month
ago in a stem cell research and therapy
journal my publication was highlighted
in several news agency with an article
entitled doing more with less
stem cells regulate their fate by
altering their stiffness so if you're
interested let's dive in one of the
biggest motivation of my study is a
disease cut or saw arthritis I'm sure
that most of you may know someone in
your extended family and friends circle
who suffers from a sort writers and in
the USA alone 10% of men and 13% of the
woman age 60 and older have been
diagnosed with knee osteoarthritis so
what is also arthritis exactly it's a
degenerative joint disease which is a
little bit the degenerative joint
disease which is characterized by
cartilage degeneration and also
overgrowth cartilage or better say
articular cartilage is a white is most
tissue which covers in the phone in
joint it enabled bones of a joint to
easily glide over one another with a
very little friction acting as a cushion
between joint cartilage can help
distribute the load of pressure and
weight over the surface of joint
it also can serve as a shot and it's
mainly composed of water collagen as you
know unfortunately cartridge it is very
limited self repair a den uyl capacity
due to its avascular nature so what are
the available solutions or treatment for
osteoarthritis of course one of the
commonly prescribed medications are
painkiller painkiller could be temporary
solution for elderly people but let's
not forget that also our Titus does not
always happen due to variant a many
young adults are also diagnosed with
osteoarthritis stemming from sport
injuries
jeans and overweight currently
replacement of an articulating joint
with the synthetic process porosity this
represents the optimal treatment for
end-stage joint disease however it has
its own limitation as a parent he even
successful implants have failure rate of
20% after 10 to 20 years so as you see
it cannot work for really young adults
there has been a great interest in
developing biological treatment for
joint repairs so what is it next what
can be the next option one of these
potential approaches this tissue
engineering which authorizes cells and
biomaterials to regenerate tissues fish
engineering is divided to is careful
based and if temple free methodologies
and the scaffold based technique cells
or harvested from body exploded in vitro
and later Stevenage careful and cultured
in presence of bioactive molecules and
implanted in vivo however is careful
free recently taking a couple free
techniques recently such as cell therapy
and gene therapy have attracted
attention more from scientific community
but you know what is very important here
it's that regardless of which approaches
desirable for cartridge estimation one
should know the development of process
of cartilage to be able to mimic their
very nature other because as you know
nature does it really the best so
cartilage isn't mainly a process called
converging ASIS I have divided this
process to two stages the first stage
starts with aggregation of mesenchymal
stem cell which starts with the
formation of turns social contacts to
adhesion proteins the initiation of this
process size bondages and
differentiation of closely packed
mesenchymal stem cells is tightly
regulated with transmembrane adhesion
proteins such as in chattering please
remember that name because you will hear
it quite often in my talk the person
leaves induction chromogenic phenotype
and is regulated by several factors such
as both factor or hormones and
mechanical forces this is stage cell
cell contact play that
important role in transducing the
mechanical forces into inter an
extracellular biochemical cues to
activation of single signaling pathways
so what is our next step in this stage -
it starts with progression of
convergences and the position of matrix
reach impulsive like and collagen type 2
the process of maturation continues as
and you can see in the carton which I
have draw in this state says start to
make distant from each other and reside
in a space that they have created this
place is called lacunae proceed further
separated from each other
the mazda3 is rich with porta glycans
and collagen type 2 shown how they can
replicate this process in laboratory
settings thankfully there is very
well-established process once you have
access to mesenchymal stem cells you can
replicate this process in vitro easily
one can obtain mesenchymal stem cells
from different sources such as bone
marrow and fat but the one we use in all
the study are from adult bone marrows
and they were currently kindly provided
from Professor even Martin's laboratory
in a hospital buzzes so what you do
after you isolate the cells first raft
expand them to have adequate cell number
then we detach them from flask and make
monodisperse solution and of course you
have the contras s then you make
solution of 1 million cell per ml in
converging differentiation video in this
corner is genetic differentiation media
you should include contour inductive
factors what are they they are called
video param there is a meta zone
ascorbic acid and etc but the most and
biggest promoter is tgf-beta one then
you add 500 molarity of the solution in
centrifuge tube twenty figure 800 rpm
for 30 minutes and you are ready to go
so that means an Avery is more
centrifuge to do you have 500 thousand
cells remember this number because this
is a gold standard number which so many
laboratories in different in so many
scientists in different laboratories
around the globe use so you cut close
the tube to make them and oxygen camera
exit diffusion and keep in culture for
21 days after 21 days you can Cory
section the pilot
visualize the postal clerk and in
demotic losing histologically standing
such as algebra while suffer you know as
you can see the process is very easy and
very very snappy so in this picture you
see the typical Australian onion below
in the palace
there is one Grand Palace and another is
small satellite Palace portrait light
hands are standing blue and silver is 10
to the nuclear fasted in pinkish red so
take a moment and look at this picture
very very carefully what attracts see
you our attention in this very specific
picture when I looked at this picture I
had a question and why the satellite
palette close to the main palette shows
stronger standing four poster glycans
and the morphologically the chondrocytes
are more mature you can see the
formation of lacunae in the satellite a
small palette this was a moment I would
call it that the neutrons hassle really
hit my head
and I was thinking why this is happening
what is the reason behind it and I had
an interesting idea I thought maybe this
is because of differences in the number
of the cells with an aggregate and
palette maybe this is small has a light
palette has a listed number for because
of that it's contribute Kondo
genetically more advanced so I decided
to make palettes with different cell
numbers is starting from 700,000 to
500,000
I chose 7,000 as this size spread or the
smallest one that you can easily handle
in the back and 500,000
as I told you before it's a coldest and
that number the different scientists use
as you see in this beautiful family
picture despite the fact that the
palette with the lowest initial cell
number which I call it from now the
initial cell number is the number of the
cells which I put in this little fantasy
tube which is here for example 70,000
has 7 times lesser comparison to the
cell visit to the palace with the
highest initial cell number after 7
there is the volumetric side between the
palette is actually differences is
negligible and after 21 days a diameter
of 500,000 pilot is only one and a half
times bigger than the 70k palette so you
see
the production of mud sex which actually
leads to increase of the size in the
toilet is more efficient in so many
thousand pallet so the next step was to
take a closer look in the pallet I want
to see this palette was almost similar
style but they show different levels of
kana genesis so I wanted to compare the
expression Porter glycans which as I
said their hallmark of Cana Genesis if
you take a look at this ultimate list
and you will notice that generally from
day seven but day 21 in all the
conditions there is increasing the
intensity of the below color and in the
both time points with decreasing the
initial cell number pallets show is
stronger expression for glycans and
chondrocyte are looking more mature this
is very interesting taste illogical
images demonstrate that impact of
initial cell number on the organization
and shape of the cells a uniformity and
intensity of the guy moisture is
affected so you see here when you change
initial cell number not only the
production is changing but also the
uniformity and intensity of the
glycosaminoglycan importance so the
first the very first idea we had was a
negative sentiment is using efficiency
in the nutrition diffusion in the bigger
pallet also high additionally hypoxia
plays a very important role
incorporation of corner genesis so
without that may be the optimal condor
genesis occurs in the pallet where there
is a proper balance between hypoxia and
nutrition diffusion so you have enough
number of the cells to actually create
hypoxic environment but also there are
not too much that you can diffuse
musicians very easily so we decided to
ask for help from modeling scientists I
believe after so many years working in
academia I believe that big science
happens when you have a lot of
collaborators from this mental
discipline because they can bring ideas
technologies and we don't all the stuff
that you can use to make your science
more meaningful so dr. Simonton occur
from ETH Zurich helped us in this
portion of the project if you model our
palette
and SS the diffusion of TDI beta glucose
and oxygen in our palates interestingly
his modeling analysis showed that oxygen
concentration at the center of the
palate is expected to be similar to the
edge of the palate with less than 10%
differences observing the case of the
500k palate so what we saw was actually
the prudent diffusion is not changing so
much as difference in oxygen
concentration predicted for different
pilots do not constitute hypoxia as even
we have moisture variation human
physiology so likewise the drop in the
concentration tgf-beta was also
predicted to be extremely negligible
however his modeling data reported that
the concentration of glucose is slightly
lower in the palace with a higher cell
number nonetheless the absence of any
remarkable differences in the diffusion
of oxygen and nutrition in the pilot
with various initials and numbers
pointed out that maybe there are other
mechanisms involved in the data which
you are able to see but you know you
have to always prove the modeling in the
next step we try to prove the modeling
data so we stand for hypoxia-inducible
factor which is called - alpha and this
expression is upregulated in hypoxic
conditions as you see mr. commissioner
images do not really show appreciable
differences between different colors so
you can see that in the palate is
starting from 7 to get to 500k the
expression of - alpha is not really
changing dramatically so in this stage
we know what is not responsible but we
needed to know what is actually
responsible for what we see so we
decided to use azimuth 16 area analysis
I know it's expensive I know it puts a
lot of burden on the lab but it really
works it because you can really get a
lot of information about your research
we use this affirmations in our analysis
to get more insight into the difference
in the gene expression level in
different conditions so I isolated cells
from different palates 48 hour post
initiation of converging differentiation
and as you can see in the map this
special
map shows top on the differentially
regulated genes as a function of
changing the initial cell number within
the palate this automatic signal
analysis should assess the gene
associated the condo Genesis and
endochondral ossification are all
regulated in palates with no initial
cell number which is actually really
good news because or we also saw that in
the palace after correction in palate
other day 721 we show that the cells the
pellet with a lower initial cell number
actually show better convergences so the
district relation of convergence
associated genes was quite expected but
what is interesting is that upon
analysis of top 300 differentially
regulated genes we were able to find out
that she's involved in regulation of
lipid storage such as caviar in one
remember the name again this is very
important for saying interleukin 6 CT 36
in firming beta 3 and is involved in
regulation of lipid biosynthesis process
and declaration of stupid transport such
as Lipton and such inducible kinase 1
well don't like related in palate with
no initial cell number so we saw all the
students but don't want a 70k palate
additionally we also didn't see any
significant differences in expression of
hypoxia associated genes such as - alpha
1 & 3 between emesis from various
initial cell numbers which also I chose
that I would come it also confirmed our
modeling data so until now we had the
hint hmm and that all hint was a Liberty
storage so let's keep on working on that
there is a strong vivid evidence that
the mechanical properties of cells can
contribute to fate choices the
mechanical property of the cell is
determind but different cellular
components such as plasma membrane and
cytoskeleton it has been suggested that
presence of cholesterol and poly
saturated fatty acid in the lipid
bilayer increases the service system we
have shown in our own lab recently that
liquid transfer also cell from a
membrane lipid bilayer composition and
this impacts therefore mobility of the
cell membrane
since several genes associated with
lipid transfer and lipid storage but all
regulated in pilot with
or initial cell number the 70k and under
50k be investigated if these differences
at the gene expression levels if
translated into changes in stiffness of
the cell this is very very exciting me3
with the work we don't hit the jackpot
so we decided to ask for help from dr.
oliver Otto who has recently developed a
new technology to assess the mechanical
properties of thousands of cells in less
than a minute this fascinating technique
is called real-time deformability
cytometry it works based on hydrodynamic
deformation of cells translocating
through microfluidic channels in a
contact free manner and how cool is that
or TDC is able to analyze more than
hundred cells per second in real-time so
to do this to this experiment we almost
have to actually travel across Germany
we are living at fiber which is in
southwest of Germany and of the only one
who also it was actually I mean he is
actually currently in graceful which is
north is so we traveled across the
country to analyze our sample but
believe me it definitely worth it I
think before going through the data I
obtained using RTD see it's better to
describe a little bit how to how we did
experiments so first I digest my pallets
and collagenase to get the single cell
suspension then the analyze the search
losing on TDC our data shows that cells
extracted from 70k pallets or bigger
than the cells extracted from the other
pallets which is actually also was able
to are able to show this data in our
histological images as just as I told
you before the cells are more mature and
if chondrocytes become more mature the
size also increases under the die and
then also added officials are told also
there is a direct relationship between
decreasing the initial cell number in
the pallet and increasing the cell size
but more interestingly the cells
extracted from 70k pallets one less
deformable than any other cells
extracted from other conditions so dr.
Oliver Otto also helps us to analyze
elastic modulus of the cell and as you
can see in the bar graph by decreasing
initial
and pilots elastic modulus is increasing
and this trend is even more appreciated
appreciable at day seven of converging
differentiation so you can see the trend
by decreasing fair number of increasing
elastic modulus excels even in day two
but the trend become more significant
more and more clear but day seven of
converging ASIS this was very
interesting data we were very very were
very encouraged by to it including
we were really encouraged by it so we
decided to take a look at the expression
of making a sensing for things with the
known world in a converging
differentiation so we saw the to cater
cell mechanic is standing let's look
more to what the poor things
in order to ascertain the mechanical
underpinning the regulation condo
genesis because of this difference
initial cell number investigated that
the expression proteins involved in cell
cell context one of the protein is known
to inhibit cell cell contact is Carolee
one it's a main staple important
residing in cold storage and chorus or
rich membrane micro domains which has
documented role in mechanics reduction
and it's also implicated in transduction
of mechanical forces across search the
junction is switch activated channel
this was the same important which i've
mentioned you before that you should
remember the name Carolee have been
implicated in the compartment asia and
regulation of many signaling events such
as emissary new wall and differentiation
to the a Depot jenna can also change
differentiation if you look at the
resemble light data you will see that
expressing travel in one inversely
correlated initial cell number within
the palette and quando genic potential
of the cell in contrast intelligent
expression showed a completely opposite
trend with pilots with lower initial
cell number already showing appreciable
expression by day two which after seven
days were to the threefold higher
compared to high initial cell number
conditions
implying that increase the initial cell
number using MSC aggregation has a
negative impact on it an in terment
expression and a stabilization so we
were able also to show similar trends
with the universe understanding as you
can look at the cross-section image of
the pallet they
of capital in one in red color is
strongly a little higher number and it's
localized in the area with a less
converging potential over expression and
gathering it is stronger in aggregate
with lower cell number and it expresses
absent in the area with less kinetic
potential if it did within the palisade
higher initial cell number like 500k and
150k the interesting inverse
relationship between these two proteins
actually which are we have a role in
making a drunk main character
construction provides evidence for us
and for others to investigate two
opposing mechanobiology mechanisms
responsible for directing condo genesis
in milan chimera stem cells I believe
curiosity is the reason behind all the
big discoveries in this stage of project
I was interested to know what a big
signaling molecules are our involvement
is a phenomena another important extreme
is on climate differentiation is
basically it's a transcriptional
activator of canonical pinned pathways
and you know canonical winter pathways
role in Amazon climate biology
developmental biology and information of
long bones and cartridge are quite well
established so I decided to look deeper
in the role of beta catenin signaling to
mitigate this I met aggregate with the
mesenchymal stem cell transfer separate
commercially available fetch RNA which
is called 70 GC it's a I think the very
first paper was published in PLoS ONE
you can boil it and you can is
commercially available so you can buy
this plasmid and this plasma is terribly
expressed beta catenin TCF reporter and
i tried to test of myself and analyze
them by parasite opt for beta codes and
transcription activity in different time
spots
transfected a machined excess of nuclei
beta catenin express always read for
supporting all brand
alpha beta catenin binding to t CF alias
green fluorescent protein expression is
induced in the search surprisingly cells
in the pallet with those initials and
number showed three-fold increase in the
percentage of GFP positive cells on the
second day of differentiation and at
stage seven of differentiation for
already increased
five for this entry going finding which
correlates very with in heaven
expression pattern provides evidence for
us that mesenchymal stem cell in the
conversation phase which means after
seven days the cytoplasmic domain of
encoding
interacts with beta catenin so it makes
stable cutting and cutting complexes
which then leads to trans regulation of
beta can see inside the nuclei and
starting signaling cascades the absence
of such differences also in a 21 so as
you look at the data I say to anyone you
will see that there is no difference is
in beta catenin
expression the basically signaling and
that means which is consistent with the
maturation of Condor Genesis process as
in because after 21 days you know all
the cells were much almost mature the
data obtained using genetically modified
cell also needs to be confirmed within
five types so what I did I you I'm not
force understanding and you said for
beta catenin in different stage of
homogeneous and as you see in the 70k
palette we have nuclear the
translocation of beta cap into the
nuclei which is not actually absorbed
with the pallets of 500 chain so the big
question comes now if this is all about
social interaction and this phenomena
should happen even in absence of convent
of the factors so if I say this is only
cell-cell interaction if it is
autonomous it should not depend on
whatever you have inside your medium so
what I decided to do then to answer this
question I removed tgf-beta out of my
equation so I removed tgf-beta for my
combo genetic differentiation
medium and this very poor I was able to
see that even in absence of such a
strong convert dr. factor decreasing
cell number increases a massive
coordinating potential as you simply add
it add a o7 order to the 70k pilot shows
signs of converging differentiation
which by day 21 in the 70k pilot you
should use a stronger expression
protocol Atkins and also cell maturation
you can see the white arrow I have shown
how the cells are residing bakunin
in day in day 21 or 70k and they are
actually missing at the edge
500 chaotic 20 want to sell more content
contents together they don't show an
expression particular Kansas 500 K which
is reverse with 70 K so as I see this
experiment short so to me this is
disperses definition autonomous so the
next question was how they can employ
this finding in tissue engineering and
regenerative medicine because as I told
before
my motivation was one of the mind one of
the my main motivation was to arthritis
in the bone and Carter tissue
engineering you know the problem is the
biggest problem is occurring sufficient
number of the cells for in visual
culture and in vivo implant implantation
because it's costly time-consuming and
actually this step becomes a very
limiting step for clinical translation
because you know if you want to get
accurate if you want it to have
sufficient number of mesenchymal stem
cells that means you actually need to
passage them massively inside the lab
that means you put them through the
culture for a long time and images are
shown that if they stay in the quarter
for a long time if you populate them
more frequently they will lose their
confident ik potential so in the expense
of losing a message converge any
potential you can actually increase
expansion time which is not really
efficient for ginger and veterinary
medicine and to address this issue we
investigated implanting few pallets with
a lower cell number in the collagen is
much it will actually lead to superior
outcome in comparison with traditional
methodology of dispersing cells when you
form it through automatic so as you know
the normal traditional cartilage tissue
engineering or any tissue engineering
you disperse you disperse mono more
dispersed single cell suspension in the
temple during your biomaterials but what
I try to do in something that I make my
toilets before yes
and then the implant to discredit laser
inside the cartilaginous matrix so after
three two days keeping the colors in the
culture I implanted four of my 7ck
aggregates
inside these College anus muscles while
in the control condition I had 1 million
is as I was
and if you wonder why 1 million because
1 million is kind of a quality standard
number for this 4 millimeter diameter
collagen is much which are available you
can commercially buy them after three
basic religion differentiation however I
saw that if the cells within the palace
were fully mature hypertrophic on
Versailles and were incorporated in the
mosques and they deposited the activity
shoe which is highly homogeneous but you
know you have to remember that the fact
that the total cell number within this
pilot condition is almost four times
less than what is happening in
traditional condition which is in the
control however they were able to
produce very uniform motorist you can
easily see that them that the presence
of putting this a 70k pallet actually
inhibited the formation of hypoxia and
necrotic zone which occurs to the
diminish oxygen nutrition diffusion in
such a large contract you know when you
have a concert with four millimeter
diameter you should expect that we will
have indecision diffusion problems and
also occurred in diffusion problems
actually this finally invalidate the
premise of our study and the mana stated
the framework for potential transfer
translational applications so with this
this is slide I would like to conclude
but I have talked about you know so
shortly I would like to say induction of
stable conversion system is uncommon
stem cells is crucial for Carter tissue
engineering and math and bone
degeneration using at the Condor
classification paradigm while
significant effort has gone into
optimizing culture condition serial
expression said in vitro for generating
advocates and member for manipulating
comrade extensive lots of converging
potential in this study we developed a
donor independent solution to address on
availability and loss upon the genic
phenotype we have demonstrated a thyroid
activation ship between the cell number
during this ms oncam allison segregation
and they're converging differentiation
potential furthermore you are able to
show that enhanced communities correlate
with the emergence of superman'
I'm an essential phenotype which is
accompanied by regulation of four teens
involved in meta meta instruction such
as Carolyn Warren and helping and to
accept the code translation potential of
our finding in the proof-of-concept
study we were able to demonstrate that
the convergence is in which we were able
to achieve a semantic a pallet is
superior to the convention conventional
approach that can be achieved and we can
achieve this by using four four letters
cell numbers so our analysis also showed
that aggregate approach will secure
outcome by inhibiting the formation of
necrotic there's on an increasing
efficiency of much except addition the
result of our study provides compelling
evidence for a role of cellular
mechanics in converging differentiation
of emesis include aggregates with
implication for understanding the
mechanism important exclusive Genesis
and MSC based regenerative therapies so
last but not least I would like to give
a very very big thank you so the list is
thought with my professor and my advisor
and professor Prasad chassis for all the
time supporting me and my ideas and also
pay for my research it dr. Oliver autumn
for doing experiments using RTD see the
assignment Monica for his support with
the modeling analysis and all the
members of current members and previous
members of Sheffield language they
provided amazing environment to work and
have fun and also I would like to thank
all the funding agencies help us get
your Institute on multifunction
biomaterials for medicine the excellence
initiative German federal state
governments and the Swiss national
foundations major grant who were
generously supported my research and
last but not the least I would like to
thank it goes cell culture team for
providing an opportunity to discuss my
research in such a nice platform so
thank you so much for listening and so
the talk is open for questions
Thank You dr. Sorrell for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar now if you haven't started
submitting your questions please do so
now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click send we'll answer as many of
your questions as we have time for okay
we've got some great questions coming in
let's start at the top starters from how
many donors did you use to generate the
data yeah that's really nice question
excuse three donors to male and one
female with the age range between 25 to
50 I'm the data I present now are from
the male donor from age of 26 but you
can also look at the other donors for
example what the female 50 which I have
in the subcommittee formation of the
article online
I have a question yes because and if you
have additional questions regarding this
answer feel free to submit them now
let's go to our next question could we
use the same protocol with urine derived
MS stem cells mmm that is one nice one
actually you know you and drive system
cells are kind of new research topic I
think in the last less than a decade or
so they have been popular I have seen
some articles discussing their condo
genic potential and I believe if they
have a converting potential then they
should this protocol should work with
them as you know the same protocol we
have to write we have used for a
different size mesenchymal stem cells
and we even got a similar outcome so I
believe these cells should not be also
different if they show proper condo
change potential
um have you checked apoptosis wait and
actually in the article we have not read
I take a look at the apoptosis but we
have looked for surviving which is the
apoptosis inhibitor protein so I didn't
present the data here because I told
this could maybe make it a bit more
complicated and time consuming but if
you look at the article online we see
that we will extend reusing monopolizing
standing within for surviving and if you
were able to show that actually its
expression of surviving is upregulated
in the palette with image with lower
initial cell numbers or creates places
which we have high condo genetic
potential they had also higher
expression of surviving more interesting
I would also say that we saw in the race
relationship between Carolyn one
expression and the surviving so in there
for example the pilots the higher
initial sense of where we saw a decrease
of survival expression and higher
expression cavity on one which means
that of course it it could not directly
look at the popped odors but it shows
that the expression of survival when
higher the rate of apoptosis should be
lower also we looked for the
proliferation rate and we also saw high
pole efficient rate in the collected or
initials and number like 70 K a hundred
fifty K
let's go to our next question what do
you see as the next step in
understanding the mechanistic
underpinnings and my next question where
do you see this being applied oh you
know I always like this the future
outlook question as I mentioned a nod in
the talk we had looked for several
mechanics transduction proteins for
example Cabul in one and Kaveri in am
etc you know role of traveling one
domestic conversion Asus is really not
known we were the very first one who
discovered all of Kerala in domestic
emergencies and you are actually
currently trying to understand the
temporal regulation of capital in
wandering and Mexican businesses and how
a knock all the knockdown of capital in
one could impact domestic on the genesis
this is specially direction we are
currently trying to go and as I said in
the beginning our main and main target
is stem cell therapy stem cell based a
generative medicine and we are seeing
this use of this application in a bone
tissue engineering and cartilage tissue
engineering
I hope this answered your question Thank
You dr. Sorrell now we'll go to our next
question what is the advantage of using
our TDC technique as compared to other
techniques as you know and if you know
the RTD C is actually a technique which
is worth using is used for understanding
the cell mechanical property
the other technique which has been used
for I would say more than a decade is at
ASM which is atomic force microscopy
with atomic force microscopy you have to
spend hours and days to sit on the
machine and were able maybe to measure
10 cells so you will be able to measure
10 cells after days and you will have a
very small population to analyze and if
you have like answer genius population
couples like Carmel stem cells and I
wish you luck for analyzing with a
message every day AFM but with RTC you
can actually measure thousands of cells
so for example if you look at the
article or it's the data I presented now
we have look for more than thousand
cells which will be analyzed and then
you load your sample you analyze and the
process takes less than a minute so the
time that you load your samples by the
time you finish the measurements it may
be I don't know three to four minutes
4,000 cells and after what of course
analysis takes some time but it's not
all so as time consuming as afm so I
would say you will have a huge
population to look after and also you'll
have better statistics which will help
you to understand them and you know the
heterogeneity of the population and I
think actually there was a the main
publication from dr. Oliver O'Toole guru
which was published in Nature Methods if
I'm not mistaken that also clearly shows
what advantage this machine has and how
you can use this understand not only the
population of emesis but also cells from
blood that is very interesting I would
recommend you to look at the paper it is
really fascinating technology and you
can buy the machine also it's available
to purchase I guess yeah
Thank You dr. Surran now have you ever
done embryonic stem cell based sulphate
analysis based on matrix properties and
actually not we have not looked at
embryonic stem cells but as I said for
this for this very specific project
videos adults drive mesenchymal stem
cells
and I have a few questions that are
asking about your Instagram account
could you share your Instagram and you
can look at my Instagram icon it's
called lady in science I am very very
delighted to share my journey in this
account and I chose I share some you
know scientific stuff some the daily
life of a female scientist and I would
really be happy to join to CEO death
called lady in science
Kahneman to be able to find me with the
hashtag yes and you can also click on
the biography tab at the top of your
screen on Malika dr. serums Instagram
and her LinkedIn are listed there that
you can connect with her as well okay
let's go to our next question are there
any changes to mechanosensitive ion
channels like piezo 1 and piezo two as
they were implicated in chondrocyte
mecco Meccano sensation and that is a
really interesting question because you
know my supervisor processor Shastri
actually discovered all of peers of one
and mechanic instruction in and neurons
so we actually when I was doing my PhD
and afterwards my post that I also
looked for the role of peers of one
specifically not Caesar two on the role
of a mexicana Genesis so to be honest we
were not able to see you the differences
and in in the role of peers or one in a
mesenchymal stem cell based Conda
Genesis a sufficient experiment that I
did also in our estimate 16 array
analysis we were not able to spot pure
one with the meaningful differences so
yeah I mean I would say we did
automatics you know they add a two and
we look at the expression system after
seven days of combat Genesis in 14 days
of college Genesis but I believe that
maybe an earlier time point much earlier
could play and it could play some ball
but our analysis didn't show any
meaningful differences I case in the
time point that I discussed
Thank You dr. Sorrell now we've getting
so many great questions coming in if we
run out of time for your questions just
a reminder that doctors forum will
answer your questions via email
following the presentation we have time
for a few more doctors forum what was
the passage number that you use for the
city and that the passage number is
actually creates the intimacy biology
animus if it's a genetic relative you
were very lucky to be able to use
passage to so we passage twice on Amazon
camel essential individual and then we
use them for all culture I would say the
comment to use of mesenchymal stem cell
octo passage for what after that I would
not use it because normally used a
differentiation potential after passage
for
the
for tri lineage differentiation tential
lmses
yes of course you know when you use a
menses you have to test them for
cheerleading differentiation we tested
them for also jenny converging ik and
advocating differentiation
dr. Strawn do you think higher number of
cells could have induced oxidative
stress in the cell um could be yeah you
know and this is I remember when I had
this paper on the review we also got
similar questions from one of the
reviewers talking about oxidative stress
but to be honest we didn't see any genes
associated oxidative any differences in
oxygen any differences ended in the
genes associated with the oxidative
interest in our aromatics genera and
also you know as I mentioned before we
didn't see much of a difference in
oxygen diffusion in our in our samples
but of course to be further studies
maybe other more elaborate experiments
can be done
and it could be discussed more what we
didn't see anything in a schematic
scenery we did after two days of
convergent differentiation
no we have time for a few more did you
see differences in expression for
fibronectin and that was a good question
actually we looked at rubbernecking
expression in the people are displayed
and also in excess of the message to
state so I developed a say in our lab
and like Eliza assay for fibronectin for
this people for the basically soluble
fiber netting the protocol how to use
Eliezer is also clearly described in the
mass curve you can go on develop it in
your lab it costs really less and it's
really easy to do so we actually looked
at as I said both syllable and fibrin my
favor life I'm making for the people of
the use Western blood and we were able
to see actually in the palace didn't
lower initial cell number which is 70 K
150k they have higher expression fiber
acting which is also you know could make
sense because fiber negative is related
to condo genesis as all of you know and
also it's on it's on the team of
beta-catenin expression so our the
fermenting expression was also
confirming the data from the
beta-catenin
aqua regulation up regulation in palace
with a low initial cell number
sister a lot of humans understand yes
great questions coming in okay time for
maybe two more did you see any
differences in proliferation of MSA and
actually yes so this comes and you know
if you remember I discussed in the
modeling data that is so difference is
in a cooler called glucose diffusion in
between lower emissions and on my
palette and palette with a higher
interval number so then we saw that the
palette with a higher initial cell
number have almost like they are
modeling so they predicted to be half of
what is in the media which is around 2.2
milligram permit and but yeah yeah there
was but in the lower is a lower initial
number pilot we didn't see these
differences but you know glucose is a
small molecule so the only factor that
can alter its diffusion behavior its
consumption rate because of that is
started to examine the proliferation
instead of mesenchymal stem cells as I
mentioned before so we looked at
proliferation capacitor atmospheres and
we were able to actually see that it may
cease within a mess I mean they're
differentiated already in the lower
initial cell number pilots were actually
showing higher penetration rate in
comparison to them and itself from
higher initial cell number so when you
look at the proliferation rate of the
pellets from higher initial cember we
actually saw the number of cells remain
almost constant over into pellets with a
higher initiation number we saw dramatic
increase almost fourfold after 21 days
which is very interesting because you
know we have also previously shown the
hypercellular cross edges basically a
way to go for engineering cartilage in
vivo yeah and also the data you can you
can see clearly I mean that they didn't
have we have presented clearly in the
manuscript so if you want to get more
information about the proliferation
delayed or understanding how we use
which methodology we use to to look at
the proliferation proliferation rate of
mesenchymal stem cells I would recommend
you to look at the or second online
thank you and we'll end with this final
question you mentioned that there is a
slight difference in glucose diffusion
could you please elaborate on that a bit
yeah this was actually what I mentioned
a little bit before so as I said glucose
is quite a small molecule so you know
what glucose defeat the difference in
glucose diffusion can only be coming
from you know higher consumption rate
and higher consumption rate comes from
you know proliferating status of
mesenchymal stem cell or any cell type
generally mesenchymal stem cells when
they go through coma genic behavior
control pointed converging
differentiation pathway they decrease
their metabolic activity so they
actually become less proliferated they
become less take on some debt exceeded
consumption rate what we to understand
why the consumption rate among masses
was increasing or it would to have high
glucose diffusion in a lower initial
number pallets we looked at as I said to
the proliferation capacity memory season
we were able to show that MSC is a low
initial term over the palace to the
lower initial cell number have higher a
pollination rate so I would say this is
a link between glucose diffusion and
also a massive proliferation potential
indoor inches and number pallet
thank you again dr. Surran do you have
any final comments for our audience um
yes I would like to thank everybody for
joining here for the talk I really
really enjoy to discuss my research with
you and I learned a lot of interesting
stuff from your questions and I would
really appreciate you if you have
further questions to contact me either
by my email or my Instagram account or
Twitter and I would also like to thank
again the keep Co cell culture team for
giving me such an opportunity
thank you getting this on - yeah very
good thank you again and before we go
I'd like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions just to remind our
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration again I'd
like to thank dr. Mallika Saran for her
time today and for her valuable research
we don't select to thank lab roots and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
fabrics will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time bye